the very best horror movies give viewers
scenes that linger
and fester in the mind like vengeful
spirits even after decades have passed
the images are burned into our
collective memories
here are the scariest horror movie
scenes for every year
since 1990. in 1990 the psychological
landscape of the united states was
complicated the paranoia and
fragmentation of the titular character
in jacob's ladder
would have been somewhat familiar to
mentally and emotionally fatigued
americans at the end of the cold war
but the singular horror of jacob's
latter extends beyond an era specific
appeal
while exploring themes from ptsd to the
biblical
the film employs a unique brand of body
horror through special effects
that were amazingly all done in camera
with none
digitally added in post-production and
that makes this hospital scene and
jacob's ladder all the more freaky
because as jacob is bound to a gurney
and wheeled past people scrambling with
supernatural fervor over the vents above
him
or rocking frantically back and forth in
straight jackets
through bloody curtains and past severed
limbs you know all that horror
was in some way very real the scene in
the silence of the lambs in which serial
killer buffalo bill
stalks fbi agent clarice starling with
night vision goggles
is a reminder of why the horror genre
has long made use of first person
perspective
most notably in found footage style
pieces to introduce a more panicked
element that hits much closer to home
the scene makes us feel like we have to
look over our shoulders for a threat
lurking just
out of frame in this scene the
perspective offered to us
is the first person point of view of a
serial killer stalking our protagonist
which makes us feel just as helpless and
at the mercy of his evil whims as
clarice
rather than pick up where the series
left off twin peaks
firewalk with me was set up as a prequel
to david lynch's iconic tv mystery twin
peaks
and didn't exactly tie up the series
loose ends possibly because he was
able to show much more of a dark side to
society than on network tv
the most terrible things that happen in
fire walk with me
are the emotional traumas suffered by
laura palmer and we all know this tragic
story only leads to her death
while it may have been unconventional
lynch's direction in this prequel
reached even deeper levels of horror
than it might have otherwise
which is why laura palmer's dream was
easily the scariest movie scene in 1992.
don't take the ring laura there's one
stephen king
film adaptation that literally has
everything you could
ever want and it's 1993's needful things
leland gaunt a disguised demon arrives
in a small main town
and opens an antique shop that offers
items too good to be true
all he asks in return is that you pull
pranks on your neighbors
what's suddenly disturbing about needful
things is that although it's clear
something is amiss
god's meddling simply seems mischievous
even harmless for a while
rather than outright evil arguably it is
the townspeople's own grudges
prejudices and pathologies that cause
these conflicts to escalate
and ultimately multiple people to lose
their lives
that psychological underpinning really
sells the unconventional
chilling horror of two women fighting to
the death in a farmhouse kitchen
can the seventh installment of a horror
franchise ever really deliver
wes craven's new nightmare managed to
with one scene in particular
part of what makes heather's nightmare
in the hospital so scary
is simple hospitals are supposed to be
safe spaces
and she has finally fallen asleep it's
also scary because it begins with
freddy's voice coming out of a child's
mouth as he stares
coldly into her face a doctor arrives
but heather's hysteria
increases as she sees freddy's hands
protruding from the doctor's coat
then looks up again to see that freddy
has somehow infiltrated the hospital
staff
the rapid escalation makes this a
genuinely scary sequence
even more so because it appears
afterward to be all in her mind
in 1995 we were blessed with the sixth
entry in the halloween franchise
halloween the curse of michael myers
managed to give us a pretty solid scare
when tommy
played perfectly by paul rudd first
meets michael
as tommy struggles to free kara from a
locked room
michael appears at the other end of the
hallway tommy's response is one of
bemusement and disbelief
then fear as he frantically tries to
break the doorknob in time with
an unwieldy fire extinguisher which
makes all of his movements seem even
more futile and frantic and
adds a little more scare value to the
scene scream's satirical approach to the
horror genre has helped it endure as a
classic
in fact scream's scariest moment lulled
us into a false sense of security and
trust
billy couldn't be the killer he'd just
been attacked
the impact of the twist was heightened
by the disconcerting sight of billy
nonchalantly licking his own blood off
his fingers
revealing that it's just corn syrup just
like they used for pig's blood and
carried
couple that with stew's sadistic grin
the explanation that the two have had a
vendetta against
sid and her family and murdered her
mother and the fact that billy and sid
just slept together
and it's enough to make your stomach
turn david lynch makes the list again
with lost highway and its mystery man
who approaches protagonist fred at a
party and claims to have met him at his
own home
what follows is one of the most bizarre
sequences of 1997
made even creepier by the earnest but
empty smile of the mystery man
his lilting voice and his peculiarly
pale makeup
he insists he is at fred's house at that
moment even as he is standing right in
front of him
the fact that the mystery man is able to
appear simultaneously so amicable and
threatening
is unreal and robert flake's performance
will haunt audiences
as surely as the confusing nightmare at
foreshadows
even if you haven't seen this version of
the film you'll recognize this scene
from 1998's ringu if you've seen the
2002 american remake
the spectre clamoring out of the
television screen in this shot
might be familiar to you as samara but
in the original movie her name was
satiko and rather than seeing her whole
face as you do in the ring
in ringu we only see her bulging eye
which is arguably even more threatening
and definitely helps lift this scene to
the number one slot for scary moments of
1998.
before found footage became an overused
trope
the blair witch project made it famous
the young filmmakers behind the project
did things in a completely new and
effective way
they ended up shooting about 20 hours of
footage for a film with minimal scripted
dialogue
editing trimmed their 20 hours of
footage down to the
sub 90 minute run time you can watch
today and one of the sequences that made
the cut
ended up earning its place among the
most iconic scenes in horror
through a handheld camera the run-down
house in the woods becomes a labyrinth
and by the time the scene concludes
you'll feel you've aged
years not just an hour and a half where
are you going i've got to return some
video names
we don't need to muse on the
unlikeliness of this scene
thanks to the comically absurd precedent
set by american psycho from the opening
scenes of the 2000 film
instead we can just enjoy it in all its
gory glory
it starts when patrick bateman played by
christian bale kills elizabeth
in some extremely bloody manner christy
who had joined them for the encounter
had climbed out of bed
earlier and begins to run on the way out
she sees the bodies of several
other women before finally escaping to
the stairs
which loop downward from many floors
conveniently
bateman has a chainsaw which he drops
down the center of the stairwell
and it somehow lands on and kills
christy in yet another bloody mess
it's hard to raise a kid it's even
harder when you look down at her and she
has the wrinkled hand of an old woman
half obscured under a veil who just
keeps on insisting no matter how
frantically you assert
otherwise i am your daughter this scene
from 2001's the others
scores extra creepy points because
there's nothing really sinister about
the old woman under the veil
except that she's well old she doesn't
even have a creepy voice
the real danger in this scene appears to
be nicole kidman's character
who violently shakes her daughter and
tears at her veil to banish the
apparition
only to have it transform back into her
confused
hurt daughter when witnesses arrive
making the mother look like the real
monster
if there's one scene that teaches us
never to underestimate the simple
elements of horror
like the sudden appearance of a zombie
it's the scene in the chapel from 28
days later
stumbling upon an abandoned church
littered with the dead bodies of the
congregation
is honestly pretty scary already and
you'd think that a response to jim's
hopeful
hello would have been just the relief he
needed when that response comes though
it's from a zombie lurching towards him
he doesn't immediately run
that changes quickly though another
zombie pops up
and soon the whole horde awakens gems
naivete
sticking around rather than running at
the first sight of the undead
gave us one of our scariest zombie
moments
the scariest scene in the remake of the
texas chainsaw massacre
and the year 2003 didn't involve a
single chainsaw
instead this foreboding scene is made
extra scary due to its pacing
and sound design a group of pigs
trundling through the living room is
weird
but not especially dangerous a porcelain
head and sewing machine on a desk is
definitely creepy
kemper sees an eerie old photograph
before hearing a sound from another room
and continuing his search for aaron the
backdrop of dismayed black and white
cartoon faces playing on the tv
as he is abruptly killed with a
sledgehammer is the perfect introduction
to leatherface the sadistic game master
has taken various forms in all manner of
horror films
but none of them quite gets under the
skin like the one and
saw who set the original reverse bear
trap
this game is so titled because the
victim amanda
has a device strapped to her head that
will when the timer goes off
rip her mouth open permanently as if
that weren't bad enough
amanda has to retrieve the only key to
the device from the stomach of her
cellmate
using a knife the creepy green light and
disorienting camera work add to the
horror
but what really gets you is the
narration amanda is telling her own
story
so you know that she got out but the
fact that you know how she had to do it
makes that prior knowledge grim
rather than comforting the 2005 rob
zombie flick the devil's rejects
surprises
us when a hotel housekeeper finds one of
the title trio's victims
wendy still alive hanging on the back of
the door
and wearing another victim's face she
collapses onto the housekeeper
screaming wordlessly from behind the
makeshift mask
before both of them make a run for it
you can honestly see the next part
coming
wendy can't see out of someone else's
eye holes and stumbles through the
desert and onto the road to flag down a
car
a truck runs her over but the scariest
part
wasn't her death it was finding her
alive and watching her flail toward her
doom
wearing another person's face the fact
that the 2006 remake of the hills have
eyes centers around cannibal mutants in
the southwestern desert hints that there
is a good bit of sci-fi involved to give
all of the horror
an extra edge the hills in which the
carter family's car breaks down are
plagued by mysterious disappearances
connected to nuclear
testing in an old mining town nearby
although we absolutely
had to see the desert didn't we bob and
if the cannibalism ghost town combo
isn't enough the impetus for the
scariest scene
is the abduction of a baby which leads
to doug's ultimate confrontation with
the mutants
which just might be the scariest movie
scene from 2006.
the first paranormal activity film
elevated the found footage
sub-genre of horror cinema whereas the
cameras in the blair witch project
were intentionally limited in scope
completely subjective
and without an omniscient point of view
paranormal activity gave us the opposite
in 2007
the cameras offered a nearly full
perspective of each room they depicted
often unnervingly so the setup in
paranormal activity makes us squirm
so much because we can see everything
but can't move
and it's night time and we're all alone
with the characters this cold distance
heightens the horror on the 21st and
final night
easily making it the scariest horror
movie scene of 2007.
this scene from the strangers was shot
so well that its
unnerving frame may be familiar to you
from the movie's promotional poster
for which it was eventually used though
the shot itself
is about as static as a still image for
a few moments
it's the chilling stillness combined
with liv tyler's
slow casual movements that make it so
creepy in the film itself
it's also creepy just how long we have
to sit and watch and wait
knowing that the intruder is standing
mere feet away and the character doesn't
know it
when will she realize that someone is
lurking and how will it happen
some jump scares are frightening because
they come out of nowhere
but this one reveals a piece of the
scare ahead of time leaving us anxiously
expecting another one at any moment
because we know it must be coming
lars von trier is no stranger to being
condemned for his art
many of his films have earned bands and
walkouts his 2009 experimental
horror film antichrist was even banned
in france
seven years after it was released this
film features many of the most
disturbing scenes imaginable
but one that really sticks is the fox
disemboweling itself in the woods
when willem defoe's character stumbles
upon the fox
he finds the animal ever so slowly
pulling the flesh away from its body
until
a lean strip of it just snaps off while
the fox's
subsequent announcement that
is viewed by some fans as so ridiculous
as to provide
unintentional comic relief the moments
preceding it
will chill you to the bone what makes
this insidious scene
in which the red demon face briefly
appears behind josh played by patrick
wilson works so well is the fact that it
hardly does
anything different from the traditional
jump scare beyond a few key elements
we've seen faces appear behind people's
shoulders before
and we've seen people freak out at
something only they can see
but what's compelling about this scene
is that the characters are talking about
the demonic presence at that very moment
and then it appears brazenly as if
daring them to speak
more the red color is also a vibrant
attention-grabbing contrast to the
shadowy forms demons typically
take in horror films most importantly
the demon appears in broad daylight
while characters are seated in a sunny
room around a table
this demon was just stopping by because
it could
now the family has to find a way to go
on with their day
most horror movies build tension in a
manner that revolves around the source
of horror itself
like poltergeist or serial killer but in
2011's you're next
the source of tension leading up to its
scariest moments
is almost always the characters the
family's bickering dominates just about
every scene with the camera and the
audience scrambling to keep up
this creates a sense of unease not
unlike scenes in which someone is being
chased or hear strange noises and keeps
turning to look
over their shoulder excuse me
you say that like it's my fault as the
details and drama unfold
we learned that this family is so
dysfunctional that a couple of the kids
have hired hitmen
in creepy cultish animal masks to
disrupt dinner time
genuinely frightening from start to
finish sinister makes it hard to pick
the scariest scene
but you know that this film is where
you'll find 2012's winner
as many delightfully disturbing moments
as there
are protagonist ellison played by ethan
hawk
stumbles upon the best one early in the
film when he's digging through
old home movies in the attic of his
family's new house
these movies depict the murders of the
previous family
filmed on a handheld camera for one
thing even if you can reasonably guess
you really don't know what's coming
you're not sure why the family made a
home video of their lawnmower at night
until you encounter the most artful and
unconventional jump scare of the year
it's not a demon jumping out at you but
it's a window
into the fact that something absolutely
sinister happened
at this house if things that go bump in
the night are
standard horror fair the conjuring was a
bit of a horror renaissance
early on the film equips itself for
sound-based scares
the parent family has a special game
they like to play called
hide and clap which is like a variation
on marco polo
yeah let's play in this scene the creepy
sound apparently comes from cindy
sleepwalking and banging her head
against the door
but after she returns to bed the sound
starts again while a minor misdirection
it was effective we thought we had ruled
out the supernatural as the source of
the sound when we discovered cindy was
causing it
meaning that we might have jumped when
it resumed or at the very least went on
higher alerts
inadvertently priming ourselves for the
fright of seeing the witch
on top of the wardrobe to make fear more
tangible to its audience
one approach is to make it more intimate
many directors choose to accomplish this
through cinematography or editing but it
follows
takes a decidedly unique and modern
approach by
tying its horror to sexual intercourse
for much of the film we don't see the
demonic entity that passes from person
to person after they've done the deed
and when we do it takes a different form
for each victim
first it is a woman which only jay the
afflicted young woman can see
however the spectre can take any form it
pleases
and could be anyone which would be
terrifying on its own
but its next iteration the tall man who
causes jay to leap out the window
is the stuff of your nightmare's
nightmares
you know you've seen a great horror
movie when a glorified folk tale can
reach nearly 400 years through the
centuries and still
send chills down your spine especially
when the title menace is only glimpsed
fleetingly for most of the story
in the witch's scariest scene the
witches have barely revealed themselves
thus far
that doesn't stop the family from going
on a witch hunt with only each other as
targets
ultimately with a little supernatural
meddling they tear
each other apart it's certainly creepy
when the witch appears in the shed
without entering through the door
but it's even more horrifying that the
children's parents locked them out there
interspersed with and exacerbating this
tragic terror
are shots of thomason's mother nursing
what she sees as her baby
while in reality a crow gnaws at her
chest
sibling rivalry can get bitter but you'd
never expect it to literally
taste sweet apparently though if you
come from a family of cannibals it can
raz justine formerly a lifelong
vegetarian
doesn't think about or behave around
human flesh as if it were just another
food or dietary preference
her cravings are pathological primal and
uncontrollable
it's genuinely terrifying to watch her
go through her transformation
and discover that her body can only
survive on human meat
but watching her examine her sister's
accidentally severed finger
then nibble it then pick it clean while
the soundtrack builds and her sister
lies unconscious in the next room
is one of the most alarming things
you'll see this year
if you didn't see raw when it premiered
in 2016.
it's certainly the most alarming thing
justine's sister saw when she woke up
just in time to see justine finishing
her snack
one of the most horrifying thoughts is
that true horror
exists not in a private hypnosis induced
nightmare but rather endemically in our
way of life
filmmaker jordan peele explained that
the sunken place in get out was a symbol
for the marginalized and all the systems
that keep
marginalized communities oppressed
specifically in this case
the impact of the prison industrial
complex on black communities
as well as the lack of representation in
film it's frightening to see chris from
the outside
paralyzed but present versus the inside
sunken and silenced the sunken place
makes every other second of get out
that much more terrifying by offering
the context
and revealing the nature of logan's
outburst and other clues
earlier in the film what may seem
inconsequential or not quite right
in film and life to those who only see a
30-second scene
is flat-out wrong for those whose
vantage point is the sunken place if
you're ever struggling to decide between
a horror movie and a dance movie
you need look no further than the 2018
version of suspiria
and after one early scene you might not
want to look any further
period not exactly a remake of the
color-saturated 1977 classic
the 2018 version follows similar themes
and characters but expands greatly on
the more abstract realm of emotional
provocation
at least that was director luca
guadagnito's intent
and provocative doesn't even begin to
cover the scene of four olga's death
at the unknowing hands and feet of susie
whose dance has been somehow
supernaturally
linked to olga's helpless body as susie
dances
olga's body is tossed and contorted
until she is deformed beyond recognition
while the original movie doesn't expose
the undercurrents of witchcraft right
away
2018s wastes no time in doing so
in overwhelmingly gruesome fashion the
scariest moment in mid samar
actually plays out on the western side
of the atlantic
not with the free falls and
sledgehammers in the idyllic swedish
mountains
not that the rest of the film doesn't
deliver but dany's family's deaths at
the hands of her sister
is more disturbing than anything else
the sound design of the reveal is
piercing
blending perfectly with danny's screams
the cinematography and editing are
dreamlike
with first responders moving in slow
motion through the darkness of the
family's home
there's something extra sinister about
killing your parents
in their sleep not to mention the
elaborate lengths to which the troubled
girl goes
plus there's the disquieting realization
that when dany called her parents
earlier in the film to say
she thought something was wrong and the
phone rang next to them as they appeared
to sleep
they were probably already dead what do
you think of when you think of ghosting
someone
if you define it the way most
millennials do as
ending a relationship with someone by
cutting off all contact without warning
or explanation
then adrian's behavior in the invisible
man of remaining in someone's life
whether they want you there or not
is pretty much the opposite but you
could say that adrian ghosts
cecilia because that's what he literally
becomes he vanishes from view
yet tortures her in plain sight while
remaining completely unseen
and making her concerns seem crazy his
actions eventually escalate beyond
psychological abuse and into taking
cecilia's sister emily's life in public
right in front of her and framing her
for it an even more chilling element of
the public murder
is adrian's remorseless display of
dominance and manipulation
in a completely inhuman act check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite scary movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one